[Music]
i'm lauren zima as a race to erase ms
gala at the Beverly Hilton in Los
Angeles the 25th annual gala and it
marked a big night for Cheryl Burke and
Matthew Lawrence their return to a
purpose of a couple so I saw your
Instagram earlier you know 11 years you
graduate a city guys raising that
haircut no haircut and that smoky eye I
was like I love it
how does it feel to be back together and
just be happy it's great it's really
great because we are happy it's such a
refreshing thing in a relationship you
know just for it to be great and
everybody be happy that means you guys
know you know we want to do this again
and even we want to hit the red carpet
or the orange carpet well for me it was
like a text message last December saying
hey wanna have dinner Merry Christmas
and then that was it then we got back
together their first carpet it feels
like a year and a half since we've been
back together so you've been kind of
like laying low Cheryl I know you've
been through so much lately with your
dad and everything and I I lost my dad
so I appreciate you sharing the you know
what you've been going through how have
you supported her and how are you doing
it's tough you know my real father you
know I have to my stepdad my mom
remarried but my real father lived in
Thailand so
barely saw him as it is so it was really
hard for me to go back there and just I
feel like I have a lot of unanswered
questions and but I do feel a lot closer
to him and I'm finding out more
information than I ever have before but
it's never easy I mean I can never you
know tell you how I feel I'm sure you
can relate to my feeling but that's the
depression and sadness you go through
you know it's still something that I'm
trying to get through but you just
there's not one second I don't ever
think about my dad so that's been
amazing he came to me to Thailand and
he's been very supportive I wouldn't
have been able to get through it to be
honest